- Grand Montréal, ce matin.
Le prix de l'essence dépasse le
cap symbolique des 2 $ le litre.
- Je trouve ça vraiment exagéré.
C'est incroyable.
J'en reviens pas.
- Quand il était à 99 sous,
le plein me coûtait 60 $ à peu
près. Mais là, il m'a coûté
120 $ le plein.- Les prix à la t
autour des 2 $ à Montréal,
Québec, et Saint-Jean,
Terre-Neuve. C'est Vancouver
qui trône au sommet de la l
à 2,16 $ le litre,
aux antipodes d'Edmonton,
à un peu plus de 1,60 $.
Les automobilistes canadiens
devront se serrer e
d'un océan à l'autre.
- C'est hrop cher. Mais je ne
sais pas la raison.
- La raison : le baril de
pétrole se maintient à plus
de 100 $, propulsé par la guerre
en Ukraine, et la perspective
d'un embargo européen
sur le pétrole russe.
JEAN-THOMAS BERNARD, Département
sc. économique, U. d'Ottawa
- C'est très élevé.
C'est élevé et stable. Donc,
ça passe dans notre facture
immédiatement et c'est constant.
- Constant, selon les experts,
au moins pour quelques mois.
- Je vais prendre moins
le véhicule. C'est tout.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAU, Chaire de
gestion du secteur de l'énergie
- Ça va favoriser la vente
de véhicules électriques,
ça va nous faire réfléchir
sur les modes de transport.
Donc, ça va permettre,
peut-être, d'accélérer la
transition vers de
de transport moins énergivores.
- L'essence à fort prix nourrit
l'espoir d'une transition
énergétique accélé
mais n'a rien pour freiner
l'inflation galopante.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Je pense que'il faut contifaur
de remettre de l'argent dans
le porte-feuille des Québécois,
parce qu'effectivement,
l'inflation est à
u élevé.
- Les mois de juin, juillet et
août ne feront pas de cadeau
aux vacanciers, qui verront
leur budget amputé
à moins de s'adapter.
- Il faut s'attendre à serrer
sa ceinture tout l'été,
et à envisager des plans
de vacances qui sont moins
énergivores, parce que c'est
certain qu'il y a un très gr5♪
risque que le conflit en Ukraine
perdure.
- On va rester localement.
Pas de... pas de roulotte.
Ha-ha-ha!
- Même avec la levée des voyages
internationaux, les vacances
mité, plus abordables,
pourraient avoir la cote
encore une fois cet été.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Mon